personnellement je trouve que il est
plus agréable d'entendre de l'accordéon
que du tambour surtout quand l'accordéon
et jouée par marcel azzola après cette
déclaration de foi marcel azzola qui est
surtout destiné à mettre en valeur
l'accordéon et l'importance de
l'accordéon dans la vie contemporaine
je crois qu'il est inutile de vous
présenter davantage vous êtes un des
plus fiers tenon est un des plus
brillants tenants de l'accordéon
français enfin détonnant enfin disons
que nous faisons aux animaux tous les
plus grands bals de france voilà vous
animez tout fait dans ces deux les
français c'est cela donne monsieur
devant vous qui fait danser la france
entière vous avez faire déjà d'audit moi
parlons de l'accordéon vous êtes plus
parisien né amélie mais en tant qu'homme
richelieu il vous habitez penta donc il
semble que vous réunissiez toutes les
conditions idéales pour jouer de
l'accordéon il faut être parisien non
pour bien jouer dix ans le musette
on en joue bien partout dans le monde
entier est ce que vous êtes d'un de ses
joueurs et compositeur d'accordéon qui
considère que l'accordéon ce n'est pas
seulement du musette pour le 14 juillet
mais que ça va plus loin
oui bien sûr que jouer je crois tous les
genres de musique avec un accordéon il
suffit de savoir bien le travail et
aimer ça quand je poète et paysan à
l'accordéon de super je veux bien mais
est-ce que vous croyez qu'on peut jouer
du tchaïkovski ou du bac on peut
travailler c'est cela oui il ya une
petite nuance d'accord
[Musique]